In this lesson, we're going to discuss mutations. Now mutations can
be good or bad depending on the individual and the context.
>> Now, a mutation is simply a change in the DNA sequence. For example, Lauren
has the mutation for lactase persistence, allowing
her to drink lactose containing products like milk.
>> Well, don't make me feel like a mutant Matt.
>> Oh well, it's okay Lauren. In the
genetics world, everybody's a mutant because mutation and variation
are pretty much the same thing.
>> So a mutation in eye color is the same thing as a variation in eye color?
>> Exactly. In this course we're going to use
the words interchangeably. So take heart, everyone out
there is a mutant for something. To help
you get acquainted with all sorts of new mutations
in this lesson, this is an incomplete concept map for you to print off and keep
along with you. Fill in the blanks as we go along. At the end of the lesson,
you'll have an opportunity to fill in the blanks
with the answers you've collected along the way. Now, if
you're someone who still needs to see the complete concept
map to learn, then please go to the end of
the lesson and download the complete copy. But otherwise,
please just use this version. Try to fill it out
as you go along. And at the end of the
lesson, you'll have a chance to see the complete version.